I'm Ben Gomes and I'm Chris hair and we
are on the Google autocomplete team and
we're about to do the wired autocomplete
interview we get to on to all kinds of
questions from all around the globe all
right why is Google autocomplete not
working when does that happen I think
that what happens yeah that's probably
you internet it's not us actually but in
fact most people when they start up
their machine to check with their
Internet's working go to google.com
simply because we're available in so
many different regions as close to a
hundred percent in the time yeah why is
Google autocomplete weird people are
weird really yes they are we ask all
kinds of questions and you know you get
what you get
why is Google autocomplete racist
unfortunately autocomplete is based on
what other people are searching for and
unfortunately there are people who have
racist views in the world and we try and
get rid of these suggestions the best we
can and if you see them report them to
us we do our best to get rid of them
please why doesn't Google autocomplete
bad words we don't have people who get
frustrated and type in bad words it
doesn't really help their search very
much and so we tend not to autocomplete
your bad words because it's not likely
to help you your frustration likely gets
in your way do you do Google employees
oh this is about us I suppose all right
here we go always get free food yeah we
do oh you betcha we do yeah we do it's
great do Google employees get free
massages one on your birthday yeah but
otherwise yeah the Google employees use
Gmail yeah we do oh yeah we didn't email
for forever Gmail was an internal
product before we gave it to the outside
world yeah
the Google employees take naps oh yeah
human we do we like people to be able to
do what makes them feel comfortable and
productive and if that means a nap in
the afternoon or do not for you to do a
better job in the evening so be it
people are very curious about what we do
bounty can Google employees read my mail
nope no no no nope nope can Google
employees see my photos again nope no no
mm-hmm
no can Google employees bring dogs to
work yeah
can we decided at some point where a dog
company can bring a cat to him he can be
a dog to work can Google employees date
each other yeah they can we're humans
too
yeah well you know the restrictions on
like dating within your management chain
but in Google employees sure there's
some pretty inked Googlers out there all
right does Google search or he's all
long these are long ones
the entire web yes the entire web that
we can see all the pages we can find yep
all of it although that we can see does
Google search use machine learning yes
we do actually we do to use machine
learning and lots of parts of Google
search it's something there's something
we call rankbrain that uses deep
learning to actually learn to respond to
give you better results over time a
great way to think about machine
learning is actually image recognition
so Google Image Search when you type in
blue car we certainly haven't had
somebody go through every single image
on the internet and say that's a blue
car that's a blue car that's not a blue
car you have a couple of examples like
that of blue cars machine learning takes
over Bob's your uncle
we now know what a blue car looks like
yep so today in mainland China Google
services are blocked
well Google search is blocked you can
see us in Hong Kong or Google Taiwan
combat TWU but in mainland China
search doesn't work today just Google
search this listen to my oh my gosh -
I'm clumsy no no no no people tend to
ask the questions that other people ask
and so it can femal but we're not
reading your mind does Google search
productize search results Google search
just progress search results and it
makes use of two things it makes use of
the how important is this page and how
relevant is it to your query and we do
this all with algorithms but we have
humans evaluate whether we're doing a
good job every time we make a change and
he make hundreds with a couple of
thousand these changes a year does
Google search PDFs yeah yep definitely
always have there's Google search
Facebook pages yeah
yeah oh if this public yeah Twitter
Instagram - yep
everything that's public mm-hmm we can
see it well search it there's Google
search news boolean I think this query
means boolean search like the kind used
to find in library is where you have to
say a and B or C yeah but we you don't
have to do that but you don't have to
speak to us like a human can Google
search oh oh yeah we can yep I tree if
you go to the Google assistant it'll
actually if it says audio playing the
background it'll say it'll ask you
what's the song and if you tap on that
it'll tell you what the song is yeah I
said pixel phone it'll tell you that
even on the home stream yeah well yeah
can Google search but nothing else this
is such the only thing Google can do i
oh no we can do great stuff yeah we do a
bunch of stuff Android in Chrome yes
assistant pixel with hardware at home we
don yeah we just do search Google
searches but yeah Google does a lot of
stuff can Google search the Deep Web I
think well the Deep Web what they're
referring to is bits of content that are
disconnected from much of the web it
thinks that this connection much of the
web then we have no way to find it then
can Google search for a face not exactly
I not really but we have this really
cool app that people are using where we
could match your face to a painting the
Google cultures yeah can Google search
history be tracked we remember your
questions or your queries from before
but you can delete them and you can edit
them any way you see fit
I hope this has been informative I hope
it helped you understand how Google
search worked a little bit better I hope
the next time you use autocomplete or
any of the Google search services you
remember the amazing people that
hopefully help make your journey amazing